[موسيقى]
نقل جتا امين الشهداء كما تشاهدون هذه من
مجدره عائله عوان هنا يبحثون عن مكان
لدفنه به لدفن جثامين الشهداء
[موسيقى]
به هذا البيت لا الا مدنيين عزل
اطفال صغار وكما انت طبعا شايف هذا الدمار
طبعا المنزل الثاني ما فيش فيه يعني كله
اطفال كلهم مدنيين عزل ما فيش يعني ولا
مجاهد ما فيش اي شيء من نوع السلاح هذا
الحرب على الاطفال كما ترون خلي العالم
كله يشوفوا هذه الحرب اللي على الاطفال
اللي بقولوا انجزنا انجزنا هذا اللي انجزه
الكيان
الصهيوني
[موسيقى]
يعني هنا يحاول الاهالي الدخول الى المنزل
وايجاد اي طريقه لانتشال جثامين الشهداء
من هذا المنزل هناك عشرات الشهداء في هذا
المنزل الذي سوي بالارض كما
تشاهدون
[موسيقى]
ا
بناتي وجوزي وابن بنتي الله اكبر ودار
اخويا وان اروح انا لمين اروح لمين اروح
ماليش حدا انا ماليش حدا قطيعه في الدنيا
عدنان وح الله يا بن بنات عطشه بنات عطشه
على 12 سنه جوني والولد هي ابني مرمي شوف
حطلع لقتيت لس جاي بسرق الولد هيه هي
شهداء شهداء هي شهداء هي شهيد هي شهيد
شايفينهم مش قادرين نطول لهم فش معدات
نرفع السقف هذا هذا السقف تحته 30 شهيد هي
ش هي شهيد يا عالم مش قادرين نسحبه بكره
الكلاب بتاكل و بدود واحنا مش قادرين
نطوله هيه شايف وهي هنا شهيد بدنا كباش بس
يرفع السقف فض نسحب الشهيد ما فيش واذا جا
الكباش بقول لك هات له وقود فيش وقود
ق في
جه بنع
لمخزن المخزن
د ايو
منحت دخل ما يحكي لا اله الا الله
هنا عشرات جثامين الشهداء كما تشاهدون على
على هذه العربه